i don't know any women that sit around  and say i don't need a man because like  they want their girlfriends to pack them  on the back i think it's more like i  don't need a man because you just been  through it and now you want to be like  you know you're going through the  emotions the feels as we call them you  break up with somebody it's never easy  for a woman you always got the nostalgia  you've got the like i hate him but i  still love him you've got the do i get  back with him all of a sudden everything  he ever did that was bad doesn't seem as  bad and all the stuff he ever did that  was good seems like he was like the guy  from the notebook  the romantic music plays way too often  in the background we're like staring out  the car window like tossing our hair i  mean you know we do it let's own it we  do it